in the global race for a covert 19
vaccine there's a new contender in
Thailand this team is working on a
groundbreaking formula called mRNA this
type of vaccination has never been
approved for public use before one of
four options being developed here this
contains a snippet of coronaviruses
genetic code when you inject from the
body the formulation will make the
vaccine moot introduce your uptake by
the cell and the cell we make protein
and the protein will induce your immune
response and the body to fight back
before they injects people they're
trying it on monkeys 13 syringes are
filled with different mixtures
they're then taken to a hatch where
they're picked up by abet the macaques
will get one injection every month for
the next three months in the monkey
there are some leak heart that is also
have the effect infection similar to the
human so we will use other monkey as a
model of what healthy the tests are
being done at this Research Center not
all the monkeys are involved in the
trial these are in the breeding colony
it usually takes an average of around
ten years to develop a vaccine but
coronavirus of course changed that what
hasn't changed is for regulators to
approve a new vaccine they have to be
assured that it's safe for use in humans
and that's where animal testing comes in
scientists in the UK and China have
already tested on monkeys a separate
mRNA program in the u.s. is studying
mice and humans but as we hunt for a
coded 19 vaccine campaigners question if
animal testing is necessary or reliable
obviously people want a vaccine for
kovin 19 but many people will find it
really distressing to think about
testing on animals yes yes so that's why
we need to balance the way you between
testing with anymore so that's why I
said that if not necessary don't do it
in monkeys but this one we have no
choice that's why we're doing in monkeys
because this could be nineteen fighters
only monkeys care less for the similar
to humans and also you can see that we
use very few monkeys in each case people
covet nineteen is transforming vaccine
development if this works it's
potentially a cheaper and quicker
alternative for poorer countries and
could be ready to use in Thailand and
seven other Asian nations by the end of
next year
Shaboom Robbins Sky News Thailand